[Musik]
nein ich komme gerade vom sport ihr
unschwer erkennen können auf jeden fall
komme ich die gerade vom sport in meiner
riesen sport mathe apropos sport am
sandra hatte letztens probetraining beim
fc bayern münchen aber darum soll es im
heutigen video gar nicht gehen freunde
sondern wie bereits gesagt ich komme
gerade vom sport und beim sport habe ich
immer diese airports drin weil das sind
so bluetooth kopfhörer von apple
die sind echt mega praktisch für den
sport also man kann damit einfach ganz
entspannt musik hören
man kann damit auch telefonieren und die
sind halt über bluetooth mit dem handy
verbunden und ich hab dann heute morgen
eine mail bekommen die 9er potro und da
habe ich mich halt schon jetzt mal
gefragt hey er potro hält apple hat das
0 angekündigt dass es neue airports
geben soll dann bin ich auf jeden fall
auf google gegangen haben airports pro
einfach mal bei google eingegeben und
das hier ist das erste bild das
angezeigt kam und schlussendlich sieht
es genauso aus wie die jetzigen er
putzen nur mit irgendwie so komisch und
gummi vorne dran das heutige instagram
schaut bekommt übrigens fabulous luke
haben denn sie hat mich hier wunderschön
bearbeitet auf dem foto also wenn
irgendein morgen video einen insider
bekommen wollt dann markiert mich
einfach auf euren instagram bildern dann
habe ich mich halt ein bisschen weiter
durch google bilder durchgeschlagen und
habe dann das hier als nächstes bild
gesehen da sind die ein bisschen größer
dargestellt und man sieht dass die ein
bisschen kleiner sind als die aktuellen
airports dann kann die neuen airports
und schlussendlich noch besser verlieren
als die jetzigen allerdings bin ich da
mal von google bilder weg gegangen und
bin auf apple.com gegangen und da
lächeln einen die neuen airports schon
so richtig riesig an
von daher werden wir kriegen einfach mal
auf weitere infos wir sehen hier schon
ganz nett die neuen airports airports
schauen uns das ganze mal so ein
bisschen an aktive rauschunterdrückung
blablabla also die ganzen neuen funktion
von den neuen airports weil die haben
jetzt irgendwie seine noise cancelling
technologie also man kann einen knopf
drücken und dann hört man nichts mehr am
einen herum das ist super wenn man im
flugzeug sind zu deinem zug und so
weiter und so fort und kann das ganze
allerdings auch irgendwie deaktivieren
indem man dann wieder irgendwie so
liegt an seinem rollstuhl oder man kann
es auch über das handy deaktiviert und
so weiter und so fort
auf jeden fall würde ich sagen schauen
wir uns die webseite erst mal noch ein
bisschen weiter an
hier soll vom typ der es könnte auch
eine friseur werbung sein spüren wirst
du nur den sound so an sich auf jeden
fall wird jeder noch ein bisschen mehr
erklärt zu den neuen airports pro und
zwar gibt es jetzt eben diese drei
stücke klein mittel groß und so weiter
und so fort blablabla noise cancelling
dies das was ihr alles für eine technik
drin haben auf jeden fall habe ich mich
dann gefragt hey ich meine ich habe mir
jetzt nicht gerade erst neu die airports
gekauft habt jetzt auch schon eineinhalb
jahre
wie teuer sind die denn eigentlich und
wie man das dann halt so macht kriegt
man einfach mal auf kaufen bei apple und
dann sieht man 279 euro
[Musik]
das sind 200 döner cheeseburger meine
ich in dünner kost nicht als 50 ist auf
jeden fall kostet diese kleinen
kopfhörer wirklich fast 300 euro und ich
meine die sind so groß 300 euro danke
aber nicht mit mir mal eine andere frage
oder wollte dass ich mir die neuen
airport poststelle und dann verlose
unter euch so dass einer von euch die
gewinnen kann lasst man leichter und bei
100000 like ich weiß es ist eine menge
aber die teilekosten 300 euro dann
bestelle ich die und wenn die da sind
mache ich ein video und dann kann die
einer von euch gewinnen muss nicht aber
kann man mal so machen allerdings habe
ich über den freizeit erst mal gedacht
da muss es doch safe schon irgendwelche
- zu geben und ich hab im ersten moment
gar nicht anders aussehen der teile
gedacht sondern nur an den preis um zu
den preis habe ich schlussendlich fast
keines gefunden sondern nur zum aussehen
und das allererste was ich gefunden habe
ist das hier und zwar ist er einfach die
bild überschrift gewesen so sehen die
airports von jedem nach sechs monaten
aus weil die einfach dieses komische
gummi da haben und da der ganze
ohrenschmalz dran kleben wird dass das
ist einfach die wahrheit und das ist
auch einfach die wahrheit genau so sehen
die neuen airbus pro einfach aus wie so
schön und ich weiß nicht ob es die neuen
airports auch in schwarz geben wird aber
dann wird aus dem in schwarzach
die seite von apple hätte apple wirklich
immer mit ihren kag design sieht man
auch bei dem neuen iphone ist einfach
auf der herdplatte mit diesen drei
komischen kameras aber jetzt bei den
neuen airports pro haben auch einige
leute gesagt dass es aussieht die
kinofans von pokémon oder wie pankow
dieser kinder serie von kicker damals
womit allerdings die meisten leute im
internet wirklich den neuen airport pro
verbunden haben ist dieses kleine
pflanzen schießt ding von plants vs
zombies ist das glaube ich und dann
haben direkt auch leute geschrieben
sowie die weiterentwicklung und außerdem
wenn es irgendwann airport proexport
proxy-server strom ex geben sollte
apropos plants vs zombies im märz ein
neues spiel herausgebracht sondern
richtig krasses hätte die box ist
erstmal zocke hier ist eine umfrage oder
schreibt mir einfach in die kommentare
ich habe auf jeden fall bock drauf
allerdings zurück zu den airports pro -
und zwar haben auch einige leute beim
eingang bilder eingereicht von wegen hey
die post pro sehen außer diese
wasserkanone von mario sunshine damals
und ich meine die haben halt leider
wirklich rechts und dann einfach
wirklich dass mir schlecht hin zu den
neuen airports und zwar haben halt so
viele wirklich immer geschrieben zu den
alten airports und auch zu den jetzigen
zum neuen airports wird auch wieder der
fall sein dass sich die leute beschweren
werden von wegen
ich habe die verloren weil die so klein
sind und jetzt mal zu mir ich könnte mir
auch wirklich vorstellen wirklich kommen
wird und zwar der airport trevor lucia r
% dann sieht quasi aus wie das hier
wieder einfach ein kopfhörer mit mit
kabel
das haus mit uns wird es so voll idioten
geben die dann vor dem laden kämpfen
werden und sagen wenn mein gott airport
in karben ii verliert dass er die aktion
handelt das soll ich will jetzt
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde eigentlich wollte ich heute auf
meinem kanal happy meals spielen das
kommt jetzt allerdings morgen also wenn
ihr der bock drauf habt dann könnt ihr
euch schon mal freuen uns schon um einen
kanal abonnieren unter den videos kostet
und dann verpasst du das video nicht
allerdings habe ich halt wie bereits
gesagt heute morgen eine mail bekommen
von apple mit dem titel luca die neuen
airports pro sind da und dann hab ich
dir halt gesehen und ich den preis
gesehen und hab teams gesehen und dann
dachte ich mir hey da muss ich auf jeden
fall mit video zu machen wenn solch
gefallen hat dann wie bereits gesagt
dass gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier dabei 100000 likes bestelle
ich mir diese kopfhörer für 300 euro und
verloren einen von euch also wenn ihr da
bock drauf habt lasst den daumen hoch da
schreibt mir gerne in den kommentaren
kleinen 2000 vom bbi spielen sollen und
ob ich dann morgen happy meals opladen
soll wenn ihr bock drauf habt und jetzt
kommt das auto
[Musik]